Générique
...
-Près de 20 %
de la population française
est en situation de handicap,
mais la société peine à inclure
ces personnes qui vivent
de nombreuses discriminations
au quotidien
par rapport
aux personnes valides.
C'est ce qu'on appelle
"le validisme".
Exemple le plus flagrant :
la scolarisation,
un parcours du combattant.
Musique légère
-On a peur d'avoir personne
les 1ers mois de l'année
et donc, de se retrouver
dans une situation où Martin
ne serait pas accompagné du tout.
-Mêmes difficultés
du côté du logement.
L'accueil en institution
est encore trop souvent
le modèle dominant.
Les associations
voudraient plus de choix
et reprochent à ces structures
d'isoler plutôt qu'inclure,
mais des alternatives,
comme l'habitat partagé,
commencent à voir le jour.
-Comment faire
pour que les personnes
en situation de handicap
puissent participer sans barrières
à la vie sociale ?
La France est-elle validiste ?
C'est le thème de ce numéro
de "Etat de santé".
-Bonjour et bienvenue
dans ce nouveau numéro.
Est-ce que vous avez déjà
entendu parler du validisme ?
Non ? C'est normal.
C'est un terme encore
très peu connu et répandu,
mais qui va progressivement
s'imposer dans le débat public.
Pour faire court,
le validisme,
c'est la conception
qui consiste à penser
que le handicap ne permet pas
de vivre, par nature,
comme les autres.
Bonjour, Céline Extenso.
Merci d'être avec nous.
On va s'arrêter sur cette notion
parce qu'elle est
très intéressante.
Elle bouscule vraiment
la façon dont on pense
le handicap.
Le validisme, vous,
quelle est votre définition ?
-C'est l'idée qu'une vie
avec un handicap
a moins de valeur
qu'une vie sans handicap
et c'est quelque chose
qui façonne toute la société.
Le handicap est souvent conçu
sous l'angle individuel
uniquement, c'est un problème
qu'on porterait en nous
et qui ne concerne quasiment
que nous, qu'on devrait
corriger, rééduquer, soigner
alors que ça nécessite
d'être pris en compte
comme un vrai sujet social et,
en effet, comme une oppression.
-En tout cas, on a l'impression
qu'on en parle de plus en plus,
on est loin du compte,
mais avant d'aller dans les détails,
on regarde votre portrait.
-Le validisme
et le sexisme sont,
selon elle, deux systèmes
d'oppression liés.
-Le fait d'être une femme
quand on est handicapé,
est-ce une discrimination
qui s'ajoute au handicap ?
-Exactement.
Parfois, le handicap
efface le genre.
On nous asexualise,
on nous considère
comme des enfants, et donc,
dénués de...
-Qui n'ont pas de sexualité.
-Dénués de plaisir, de désir,
de vie sexuelle, de vie amoureuse.
On en prend conscience
dès l'enfance
parce qu'on n'est pas projeté
dans une vie amoureuse.
On nous dit pas :
"Alors, tu as
"un petit amoureux,
une petite amoureuse ?"
On ne nous projette pas
dans une vie de parent,
d'époux, d'épouse.
-Alors que vous avez
les mêmes envies
que les autres.
-Oui. Ma vie sociale
et amoureuse est très riche
et va bien,
mais on sent ça très jeune.
-"Dégenré", comme on dit,
dans le regard des autres,
mais le regard des autres,
justement, de la société,
il n'a pas évolué,
quand même ?
-On est de plus en plus présents
dans la vie ordinaire,
dans la société,
dans les villes, dans les écoles...
et le simple fait
de cohabiter
force les gens
à ouvrir un peu les yeux
sur la réalité de nos vies,
loin des fantasmes
validistes véhiculés,
mais ces préjugés-là
s'accrochent
et mettent beaucoup de temps
à se défaire.
-On a voulu voir
quelle était la situation
de la représentation
du handicap
dans les médias
d'une façon générale
et à la télévision
en particulier. Infographie.
-Lorsque vous allumez
votre télévision,
qui voyez-vous ?
Dans 94 % des cas,
une personne valide.
Pourtant, près de 20 %
de la population française est
en situation de handicap. A l'écran,
l'un des grands moments
de la médiatisation du handicap,
c'est bien sûr
lors de Jeux Paralympiques.
Ils existent depuis 1960,
mais il a fallu attendre 2016
et les Jeux de Rio
pour qu'ils soient
retransmis en direct
à la télévision française.
Les athlètes paralympiques
font souvent partie
de ces personnalités
en situation de handicap présentées
comme inspirantes et héroïques,
dont on attend
des leçons de vie.
C'est ce que les activistes
anti-validistes
appellent "l'inspiration porn".
Alors, les personnes handicapées
doivent-elles remporter une médaille
ou traverser la Manche à la nage
pour avoir leur place
dans les médias ?
Peut-être pas
du côté de la fiction,
où les personnes perçues
comme handicapées
sont mieux représentées,
mais encore trop souvent jouées
par des acteurs valides.
Afin qu'elles soient vues
telles qu'elles sont,
il faudrait commencer
par les inclure
de l'autre côté de la caméra.
En 2021, c'est dans le secteur
de l'information
et de la communication
que le taux d'emploi
des travailleurs handicapés
était le plus bas.
Tous secteurs confondus,
le taux de chômage
des personnes en situation
de handicap est de 14 %,
presque le double de celui
de la population générale.
Buzzer négatif
La télé représente mal
les personnes handicapées,
mais reflète très bien
le manque d'inclusion
de notre société.
-Il y a quelque chose
qui m'intéresse beaucoup,
c'est que vous dites
que le Téléthon, qui est
le moment fort où on va parler
des maladies rares
et aussi du handicap,
vous dites :
"Le Téléthon, finalement,
"la façon
dont on parle de nous,
"c'est pas terrible."
Pourquoi ?
-C'est une communication
uniquement tournée vers la charité,
vers cette idée que nos vies
ne pourront avoir de salut
et ne pourront être valables
que dans la guérison,
que le seul rêve, le rêve suprême
de chaque enfant handicapé,
doit être de marcher.
Alors, on n'est pas
contre la médecine,
la recherche, on est OK
pour mieux vivre,
on veut des traitements
qui nous permettent
de vivre plus longtemps
et dans de meilleures
conditions,
mais le Téléthon véhicule
vraiment cette idée
d'une normalisation
à tout prix.
-C'est le but de la médecine aussi,
par nature.
-La médecine devrait viser
une qualité de vie
et pas une normalisation
à tout prix.
-Vous parlez aussi
de la bienveillance.
C'est vrai qu'on est portés
à apporter un regard bienveillant,
à aider, à avoir peut-être un peu
de condescendance, de commisération.
La bienveillance, pour vous,
c'est pas ce que vous attendez.
-On parle de
"validisme bienveillant".
Il y a une forme de validisme
qui va être un rejet assez frontal,
un peu hostile,
d'exclusion,
mais il y a aussi énormément
de validisme bienveillant
qui nous pèse au moins autant...
-Ah oui ?
-...et qui est
encore moins reconnu.
Ca va être
de l'aide non sollicitée.
-Par exemple ?
-Venir pousser dans la rue
une personne en fauteuil
ou aider à traverser
une personne aveugle,
mais sans nous demander
si on en a besoin.
C'est considérer
que seuls, on n'est pas capables,
que seuls, on...
Les gens paniquent de nous voir
seuls dans l'espace public.
-Ils vous croient perdus.
-C'est ça, comme un enfant.
-Vous le ressentez comme ça.
-C'est super violent,
en fait.
Les gens viennent
nous dire spontanément
qu'on est courageux,
que c'est triste.
-"C'est triste, ce que vous vivez."
-C'est ça.
-Vous êtes allée à l'école ?
-Je suis allée à l'école.
En maternelle et primaire,
ça s'est très bien passé,
j'ai été intégrée,
et au moment du collège,
j'ai dû être
institutionnalisée
parce que c'était en 1990
et les établissements scolaires
de ma petite ville
n'étaient pas accessibles.
-Institutionnaliser,
c'est fondamental
dans votre combat.
C'est entrer
dans une institution.
Faut-il toutes les fermer ?
On aborde ça plus tard.
Marianne Cazaux,
journaliste de "Etat de santé,
est allée constater
comment se passait l'inclusion
dans une école à La Rochelle.
On a beaucoup parlé
de l'inclusion,
il y a eu beaucoup
de discours politiques
autour de
l'inclusion scolaire.
Ca ne semble pas encore
totalement satisfaisant.
On regarde ce reportage
signé Marianne Cazaux.
Musique douce
-Delphine Ganne
avait un rêve :
voir son fils
vivre une scolarité ordinaire
avec tous ses camarades,
mais chaque midi,
la réalité se rappelle à elle.
Martin n'est pas accepté
à la cantine
sans une aide humaine.
Il souffre d'une paralysie cérébrale
qui le handicape
dans certains mouvements
et apprentissages,
mais pour sa mère,
Martin a toute sa place
dans une école ordinaire.
-L'important,
c'est qu'il puisse avoir
des copains
comme tout le monde,
une sociabilisation
comme tout le monde
et qu'il ne rencontre
pas forcément
que des copains handicapés
comme lui, en effet,
parce que je veux
qu'il puisse avoir
une grande ouverture d'esprit
vis-à-vis de tout.
-Le rêve de Delphine
n'est pourtant pas utopique.
Dans cette école
de La Rochelle,
la révolution de l'inclusion
a bien lieu,
dans la cour de récré
comme en classe.
Brouhaha
Pour faire les exercices de maths
comme tous ses camarades,
Oscar a besoin
de quelques aménagements
et de l'aide de Pascal.
Il est AESH,
accompagnant d'élève
en situation de handicap.
-Là, tu vas avoir ce qu'on appelle
le reste. Ca va être combien ?
Bien. Parfait.
Comme ton logiciel te permet pas
de le faire... 67...
Oscar murmure.
-Exactement.
-Ca fait 4.
-D'accord...
-On va corriger...
-Donc, ton résultat,
tu vas l'écrire ici...
sur cette colonne-là.
-En parallèle
des classes ordinaires,
les élèves bénéficient
d'enseignements personnalisés.
Les aidants s'adaptent
aux difficultés
et au rythme de chacun.
Ici, les moyens humains
sont renforcés
avec cinq accompagnants
et une enseignante spécialisée
pour huit enfants.
-Très bien. Voilà notre 1er mot.
-Il faut plusieurs syllabes
pour former des mots.
Quel mot on pourrait faire ?
Euh... Ca, ça fait quoi ?
"Lai-ne".
Est-ce que ça, ça fait un mot ?
Tu le connais, ce mot ?
-Ouais.
-Bon, ben OK.
-Jessica accompagne Rosario
depuis deux ans.
Elle rit.
-Ouais !
Un western.
Tu sais ce que c'est, un western ?
Oui, non ?
OK. C'est avec des danseurs
ou avec des cow-boys ?
Avec des danseurs ?
Non, c'est avec des cow-boys.
-Elle a appris à le connaître
et à le comprendre
grâce aux ergothérapeutes,
kinés et psychologues
qui viennent sur place
chaque semaine,
mais surtout grâce au temps.
-Le petit garçon
que j'accompagne
est en train de faire des progrès,
c'est même vertigineux, en fait.
C'est impressionnant
et on se rend compte
au fil des jours,
depuis quelques mois,
qu'il en sait beaucoup plus
que ce qu'on pensait
et tout ça, c'est à force
d'observation,
d'écoute, de patience.
Pour ces enfants-là,
c'est... Pour moi,
c'est essentiel de les accompagner
sur le long terme.
Ils ont vraiment besoin,
eux aussi,
de nous connaître
et de nous faire confiance.
-Malheureusement,
cet accompagnement pérenne
n'existe pas
dans toutes les écoles.
Dans certaines académies,
les AESH manquent à l'appel.
D'après un rapport...
Pour les parents,
c'est une source d'angoisse.
Chaque année, Delphine remplit
un dossier comme celui-ci.
-Ca, c'est notre 4e dossier MDPH
d'orientation scolaire
et de demande d'AESH pour l'école.
-Malgré la notification
de la Maison Départementale
des Personnes Handicapées
lui accordant une aide,
Delphine a vu passer
cinq AESH différents
en quatre ans
de scolarité de Martin
et la plupart ne sont restés
que quelques mois.
-On a même peur d'avoir personne
pendant les premiers mois de l'année
et de se retrouver
dans une situation
où Martin ne serait pas accompagné.
Finalement, c'est catastrophique.
Ca veut dire qu'il avance pas
comme il pourrait avancer
avec l'aide d'une AESH.
-Malgré ses désillusions,
elle ne perd pas espoir.
-Regarde comment je fais.
-L'année prochaine, elle demandera
que Martin soit orienté
vers un dispositif inclusif,
comme celui de La Rochelle.
-Alors, évidemment, Céline Extenso,
quand on voit ce reportage,
on se dit, quand même, ça avance.
-Alors, ici, ce qu'on voit,
c'est une forme de classe ULIS
qui est, pour moi,
une semi-inclusion.
En fait, c'est une inclusion
d'un groupe d'enfants handicapés
dans un endroit de l'école, mais...
-Ils vont à l'école,
mais ils restent entre eux ?
-Spatialement, ils restent
dans un coin de l'école,
et les interactions...
-Le progrès,
c'est qu'ils sont à l'école.
Ils sont pas en dehors de l'école.
C'est une demi-inclusion.
C'est une semi-inclusion.
Encore un effort.
-Ouais.
-Je voudrais parler
de l'accessibilité
des bâtiments.
Sur 100 % de vos amis, chez combien
vous pouvez passer une soirée ?
-Moins de 10 %.
J'invite.
-Vous pouvez pas aller chez eux ?
-Non.
-10 % de vos amis.
-Ouais.
-Tout est dit.
-Ca modifie complètement
la vie sociale.
C'est super important
de pouvoir se rendre chez des amis.
C'est pas seulement être invité
à manger,
c'est pouvoir passer
à l'improviste,
venir aider à garder les enfants,
déposer des courses...
Ca fait partie de toutes ces choses
qui font une vie,
une relation.
-Tout le monde peut le comprendre.
Il y a eu une loi en 2019,
la loi Elan,
qui impose aux constructions
20 % minimum d'accessibilité
aux handicapés.
-Avant, depuis la loi 2005,
l'objectif affiché était 100 %.
Cette loi Elan a fait reculer
à 20 %.
C'est un recul.
-Qui était justifié
par une forme, j'imagine,
de réalisme ?
"Il vaut mieux imposer 20 %
"pour que ce soit appliqué
que 100 % qui ne le sont pas" ?
-C'est ça.
-C'était la logique, j'imagine.
Pour vous,
ça a été une régression ?
-C'est une catastrophe, vraiment.
Il y a constamment des dérogations,
des reports,
et énormément d'établissements
arrivent à se soustraire
à l'obligation.
-Evidemment, cela nuit globalement
à l'autonomisation,
la difficulté de trouver
des logements accessibles.
Alors, il y a des solutions
qui émergent.
Marianne Cazaux s'est rendue
dans une colocation
qui est accessible,
entièrement,
qui permet aussi
à des jeunes adultes
en situation de handicap
de prendre leur indépendance.
On regarde ce que ça donne
et on en parle juste après.
-Bonjour.
Bienvenue à la Villa Maya.
-Comme tout jeune de 22 ans,
Duarte ne cache pas
son enthousiasme...
-Avec un petit coin télé,
des canapés...
-...à nous montrer
son 1er logement.
-Ici, nous sommes
dans la partie cuisine,
où nous préparons les repas.
-Mais pour lui,
cela a un sens tout particulier.
-Ici, on est dans ma chambre,
décorée par mes soins.
-Auparavant, Duarte vivait
dans un foyer, la semaine,
et chez ses parents, le week-end.
En institution,
son temps était rythmé
par les heures de soins,
de lever, de coucher,
et les repas.
Un emploi du temps rigide
auquel il ne voyait
aucune alternative,
avant de découvrir
Le Club des 6,
à l'origine de ce logement.
Elle a été pensée
par deux soeurs : Maïlys Cantzler
et Maïté Borde
pour que leur soeur
puisse quitter le cocon familial
et prendre son indépendance,
malgré son handicap,
grâce à la colocation.
C'est aussi ce que souhaite Duarte,
Alexandre, Cédric et leurs trois
autres colocataires.
Grâce à la mutualisation
de leurs aides,
ils peuvent bénéficier,
sans reste à charge,
de la présence d'intervenants
en permanence à leur côté
en cas de besoin.
Et uniquement
-Tu veux les mettre...
-Ils sont aussi autonomes
que possible.
Comme tout jeune
qui quitte le foyer familial,
ils apprennent
à se débrouiller seuls.
-On aide, mais d'eux-mêmes,
ils vont nous dire :
"Ca, laisse, je peux le faire."
En structure, j'étais habituée
à faire pour les autres.
Ici, c'est l'inverse.
Même pour leur autonomie,
leur estime,
c'est plus sympa
quand on arrive à faire les choses
que d'avoir quelqu'un
qui vous fait tout le boulot.
Ils sont chez eux,
et ça s'accompagne
dans la dynamique.
Ils font aussi des choses chez eux.
-Chaque midi, les colocataires
déjeunent tous ensemble.
Pour eux, la vie en communauté
n'est pas qu'une commodité.
Ils rient.
Comme dans toute colocation,
ils se sont choisis
en fonction de leurs affinités.
-Fifi.
-Ben oui.
-Fifi ?
-Oui.
-Qu'est-ce qu'on prend comme apéro,
aujourd'hui ?
-J'avais pensé à du Coca-whisky.
-Ouf !
Cris de dégoût
-Mais alors que le week-end
s'organise dans la salle à manger,
Cédric, lui, pense à son futur.
Plus autonome que les autres
habitants de la villa,
il a choisi ce studio
avec sa propre kitchenette.
A 32 ans,
il voit la colocation
comme un tremplin
vers d'autres projets.
-Malgré ses troubles
du mouvement et de la parole,
il a pu suivre des études.
Il est diplômé d'un master
de marketing international.
Il cherche aujourd'hui
à faire un stage en entreprise.
En attendant
de débuter sa carrière
et d'avoir sa propre famille,
il peut compter sur celle
qu'il a choisie ici,
dans la Villa Maya.
-Alors, ce jeune homme de 22 ans,
Duarte,
c'est quand même bien
d'être passé d'une institution
à une forme d'autonomie,
une vie plus personnelle.
-On voit dans le reportage
que pour lui,
venant d'institution,
il imaginait
que rien n'était possible,
et on lui a proposé
cette colocation,
cet habitat inclusif,
et il a trouvé ça génial.
Evidemment, ça paraît mieux,
mais pourquoi on ne lui a jamais dit
qu'il pouvait avoir autant d'aide,
de meilleure qualité,
seul, chez lui ?
-Alors, racontez-nous.
Vous, vous êtes chez vous.
Vous nous parlez de ce système ?
-Voilà. Je suis accompagnée
24 heures sur 24.
J'ai 6 auxiliaires de vie
qui se relaient sur la semaine.
Ils viennent le matin,
ils repartent le lendemain matin.
C'est une liberté absolument totale,
et prise en charge par les MDPH,
par l'Etat.
-Donc, vous n'êtes jamais
à court de solutions,
grâce à cette présence ?
-Voilà.
-Et cette présence,
elle coûte plus cher
à la puissance publique,
à la sécu,
aux caisses de prise en charge,
que si vous étiez
dans une institution ?
-Non. C'est ça qui est fou :
la société qui cherche
à faire des économies sur tout
ne prend pas en compte...
-Ca coûte moins cher ?
-En fait, une institution,
c'est des aidants quotidiens,
mais c'est aussi énormément
de frais de gestion.
C'est des bâtiments à entretenir,
c'est énormément de frais annexes.
-Il y a une évaluation indépendante
qui a été faite ?
-Il y a des évaluations
qui ont été faites
à l'étranger.
Je pense qu'en France,
il faudrait faire une vraie étude,
mais toutes les observations
semblent le prouver, ouais.
-Donc, si on suit votre logique,
Céline Extenso,
il faut fermer les institutions
et donner à chaque handicapé
la possibilité d'avoir
ce type d'accompagnement permanent ?
-Oui, mais je pense
que ça se passera dans l'autre sens.
On ne va pas mettre
tout le monde dehors.
-Je fais de la provoc'.
-Voilà, mais dans l'idée, oui.
-Mais dans l'idée, oui ?
-A terme, il faudra en venir là.
-Est-ce une idée
qui commence à irriguer
la réflexion de ceux
qui se préoccupent de ces sujets ?
-Oui. C'est une idée sur laquelle
on est en retard, en France.
D'ailleurs,
il y a l'ONU qui a fait
un rapport très sévère
sur l'état
de la politique handicap française
par rapport
à la désinstitutionnalisation,
en particulier,
et qui somme la France
d'accélérer le mouvement
pour permettre aux gens
de vivre de façon autonome
et de sortir des institutions.
-Vous savez, une des règles,
une des traditions
de cette émission,
c'est de permettre à l'invité
de poser une question
à un représentant
de l'Assemblée nationale.
Vous avez demandé
à Sébastien Peytavie,
député de la NUPES de Dordogne,
coprésident du groupe d'étude
handicap et inclusion
à l'Assemblée :
"Quelle serait pour vous
"la première mesure
à porter
"pour progresser
vers la désinstitutionnalisation
"en France, tel que demandé
- vous en parliez - par l'ONU
"dans son rapport
du 14 septembre 2021 ?"
Voici sa réponse.
-On peut pas fermer des institutions
si on n'a pas de quoi accueillir.
Sinon, on va le faire
avec un accueil
qui sera pas satisfaisant
et qui va mettre en danger
beaucoup de personnes,
avec cet accueil.
Si on ne met pas les moyens humains,
au niveau de la formation,
notamment,
et puis des moyens financiers,
au niveau de l'adaptation
des bâtiments recevant du public,
on ne pourra jamais arriver
à une désinstitutionnalisation.
-Voilà. Pour Sébastien Peytavie,
il faut des moyens supplémentaires
sur la formation,
sur l'accessibilité,
avant de fermer les structures.
Vous êtes d'accord ?
-On est d'accord. Il faut vraiment
penser la désinstitutionnalisation,
avant tout,
en termes de propositions
et de moyens.
A mon avis,
les moyens existent déjà.
Je pense qu'il faut réellement
penser vie autonome.
-Merci.
Je voulais vous parler d'optimisme,
mais j'ai peur
d'être bienveillante.
Quand même, si ?
-Je le suis.
Pour être militante,
il faut garder
un minimum d'optimisme.
-Bien sûr.
-Autant que de colère.
-Et vous dites ça
avec un grand sourire.
Merci d'être venue,
Céline Extenso,
dans ce numéro d'"Etat de santé".
Merci à tous de nous avoir suivis
et à très vite sur LCP.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
Générique
...